Bradley Cooper is completely focused on
his career and his daughter following
his split from Irina Shayk family is
everything the couple broke up after
four years of dating earlier this month
and our source says they're 100% on the
same page about making sure their
two-year-old daughter is happy and cared
for Bradley and Irina are feeling a
sense of freedom and both are relieved
to find time to focus on their careers
and spend quality time with their
daughter the source adds that dating
isn't a priority for either of them I
just want to take another look at you
despite rumors Lady Gaga had anything to
do with the split
our source notes that Gaga and Bradley
are still very close friends the fact
that we forged a friendship by creating
art together is kind of the most idyllic
way to to use that chemistry Bradley and
Gaga hoped to work together again and
their friends believe for the time being
they are co-stars
and great friends meanwhile Gaga's
ex-fiance Christian Kirino recently
caused a social media stir when he hit
like on a sexy pic of Irina on Instagram
following her breakup however our source
said he had no intention of being Teddy
Christian liking Irina's Instagram photo
is just his way of being supportive of
her
[Music]